it's real times 24 things you don't know
about Lindsey Graham my spirit animal is
the jellyfish
when I was in school the kids would
tease me by calling me Lindsay if you
saw just 5 seconds of the videotape
trump has on me everything would
suddenly make sense Halloween I went as
the Lindsey Graham from the Clinton
impeachment for three weeks in 1992 I
was married to Liza Minnelli John
McCain's last words to me were let go of
my hands
[Applause]
[Laughter]
president drug once told me I was like
the son he never had
because he paid the woman to have an
abortion
my favorite James Bond movie is a
dough yucky to think about that I once
kissed Trump's ass so hard I could taste
Hannity
you